Narrator:
WELCOME TO THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESS.
SO,
TELL ME YOUR SALES.
JUST OVER
$30 MILLION.
WOW.
WHOA.
IF THE SHARKS
HEAR A GREAT IDEA...
BA-BAM!
...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY
AND FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A DEAL.
I'LL GIVE YOU $200,000.
I WANT 50%.
OH,
YOU'RE SO GENEROUS.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $200,000
FOR 25%.
I'LL --
I'LL GO DOWN TO 25%.
HMM, NOW IT GETS INTERESTING.
AND NOW IT GETS INTERESTING.
Narrator: BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR...
OHH.
...OR THEY'LL WALK AWAY
WITH NOTHING.
OOH.
BUT KEVIN'S ALMOST RIGHT, RIGHT?
AND HE'S --
HE'S ALWAYS RIGHT.
YOU BETTER ROLL UP YOUR
PANT LEGS WHEN YOU SAY THAT.
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
DAYMOND JOHN DOMINATED
THE FASHION WORLD WITH FUBU.
NOW HE'S THE BRANDING EXPERT
BEHIND MULTIPLE GLOBAL BRANDS
GENERATING BILLIONS IN SALES.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
OVER 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
RENOWNED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
FIRST INTO THE TANK IS
AN INNOVATIVE PACKAGING COMPANY
DESIGNED FOR SUPER FANS.
HI, SHARKS.
I'M BRITTANY HODACK.
AND I'M KIM KAUPE.
AND WE'RE ENTERTAINMENT
SUPER FANS
FROM NEW YORK, NEW YORK.
TODAY, WE'RE HERE
SEEKING $725,000
FOR A 10% EQUITY STAKE
IN OUR COMPANY, ZinePak.
WOW.
WHOA.
SUPER FANS ARE
EVERYWHERE.
THEY PAINT THEIR FACES
ON GAME DAY,
HEAD TO MIDNIGHT MOVIE PREMIERES
IN COSTUME,
AND THEY'VE SEEN
THEIR FAVORITE BAND
PLAY LIVE 37 TIMES.
OUR PRODUCT, ZinePaks,
SPEAK TO THIS AUDIENCE
WITH THE ULTIMATE
FAN COLLECTIBLE --
EXCLUSIVE MERCHANDISE
AND MAGAZINES AND MUSIC.
OUR ZinePaks HAVE CAUGHT
THE ATTENTION
OF SOME PRETTY BIG STARS.
OUR CLIENTS INCLUDE KATY PERRY,
BRAD PAISLEY,
KISS,
AND FLORIDA GEORGIA LINE,
JUST TO NAME A FEW.
BUT NOW WE NEED YOUR HELP TO
EXPAND BEYOND THE MUSIC INDUSTRY
SO THAT SUPER FANS EVERYWHERE
CAN HAVE ZinePak PRODUCTS
FOR THE MOVIES, VIDEO GAMES,
AND TEAMS THEY LOVE.
OUR PRODUCTS ARE
BEST APPRECIATED UP CLOSE.
IN ADDITION TO SOME OF
OUR FAVORITE PRODUCTS,
YOU GUYS WILL FIND
A SURPRISE INSIDE
THAT YOU
JUST MIGHT LIKE.
Greiner: THERE'S A LOT
OF SURPRISES HERE.
OHH! I LOVE THIS BOOK.
[ CHUCKLES ]
IS THIS A MAGNET?
THOSE ARE TRADING CARDS.
TRADING CARDS.
YOU EACH HAVE YOUR OWN
COLLECTIBLE TRADING CARD.
WHY -- WHY DON'T YOU WALK US
THROUGH YOUR BUSINESS MODEL.
SO, LIKE A LOT OF START-UPS,
WE'RE CONSTANTLY EVOLVING.
OKAY.
WHEN WE LAUNCHED THE COMPANY
3 1/2 YEARS AGO,
THE PROBLEM THAT WE WERE
TRYING TO SOLVE WAS REALLY
HOW TO MAKE PHYSICAL MUSIC
TANGIBLE AND RELEVANT.
AND OUR INSIGHT
WAS THAT PHYSICAL MUSIC
ISN'T SUPERIOR
TO DIGITAL MUSIC.
WHY WOULD YOU GET IN YOUR CAR,
DRIVE TO THE STORE, BUY A CD,
IF YOU WEREN'T GETTING
ANYTHING THAT WAS BETTER
THAT YOU COULD JUST DOWNLOAD
ON YOUR COMPUTER
OR STREAM ONLINE?
SO YOU WERE TRYING TO SUPPORT
THE DISTRIBUTION OF PHYSICAL CDs
WITH ADDITIONAL CONTENT?
YES.
YEAH, SO IF YOU'RE --
OKAY, SO JUST TELL US HOW --
TELL US YOUR MODEL...
YEAH, TELL US HOW IT WORKS,
HOW YOU MAKE MONEY.
...WHERE YOUR REVENUES ARE,
HOW YOU MAKE MONEY, ET CETERA.
SURE.
YEAH, SO, WHEN AN ARTIST
IS PUTTING OUT AN ALBUM
OR DOING A TOUR
OR ANYTHING,
THEY COME TO US AND SAY,
"WE WANT TO CONNECT
WITH OUR SUPER FANS
IN A WAY THAT'S REALLY ENGAGING
AND ON OUR TERMS."
SO, IF YOU GUYS WILL
LOOK AT THE BRAD PAISLEY
SAMPLE THAT YOU HAVE --
THIS IS BRAD'S ALBUM RELEASE
THAT CAME OUT ABOUT A MONTH AGO.
SO...
Herjavec: AND WHERE DOES
THIS COME? DOES IT --
THIS IS IN WALMART.
OH, IT HAS THE RECORD
RIGHT IN IT?
Hodack: YEAH. SO, THIS IS
THE DELUXE PACKAGING.
Herjavec:
THAT'S VERY CLEVER.
ALL RIGHT, SO, TELL ME YOUR
SALES FOR THE LAST 12 MONTHS.
WELL, YEAR-TO-DATE,
WE'RE A LITTLE OVER $3 MILLION.
OUR ZinePak PRODUCTS,
SINCE WE LAUNCHED
3 1/2 YEARS AGO --
JUST OVER $30 MILLION
IN WALMART STORES.
WOW.
SO, A MUSIC PRODUCT,
AS YOU GUYS KNOW, IS 100% --
SO, YOU'RE BASICALLY
A PACKAGING AGENCY, RIGHT?
THEY'RE AN AGENCY.
WE ALSO DO
A LOT MORE THAN THAT.
SO, FOR THE FIRST
COUPLE OF YEARS,
WE WERE JUST FOCUSED
ON SOLVING THIS PROBLEM
OF HOW DO WE MAKE
MUSIC RELEVANT AT WALMART.
AND OUR CELEBRITY CLIENTS
CAME BACK TO US AND SAID,
"WE LOVE WORKING WITH YOU,
BUT WE'RE NOT GONNA HAVE
ANOTHER ALBUM FOR TWO YEARS.
SO, WHAT CAN WE DO
IN THE MEANTIME?"
SO, THAT'S WHEN
WE STARTED EXPANDING,
AND ALL THE OTHER PRODUCTS THAT
YOU GUYS SEE IN FRONT OF YOU
CAME OUT OF THAT INSIGHT,
SO --
BRITTANY, HOW DID YOU --
HOW DID YOU COME TOGETHER?
THE TWO OF US MET
IN LATE 2010.
WE WERE WORKING AT AN
ADVERTISING AGENCY IN NEW YORK.
THE IDEA FOR ZinePak WAS
ONE THAT I HAD IN COLLEGE.
I WAS INTERNING
FOR A MAJOR RECORD COMPANY,
AND EVERY INDUSTRY EXECUTIVE
WOULD SAY,
"NOBODY'S BUYING
PHYSICAL MUSIC."
AND I THOUGHT,
"WELL, THAT'S BECAUSE
NOBODY'S MAKING PHYSICAL MUSIC
SUPERIOR TO ANYTHING ELSE."
AND I WORKED AT A COUPLE
OF OTHER RECORD COMPANIES
AFTER I GRADUATED,
AND NOBODY LIKED THIS IDEA.
[ LAUGHS ]
I WAS ACTUALLY TOLD
BY MY BOSS AT ONE POINT,
"I DON'T PAY YOU
TO HAVE IDEAS.
I PAY YOU TO IMPLEMENT
THE IDEAS I GIVE YOU."
AND I MET KIM.
Kaupe: [ LAUGHS ]
AND KIM HAD SIMILAR FRUSTRATIONS
FROM THE PUBLISHING INDUSTRY,
AND WE SAID,
"YOU KNOW WHAT?
IF WE DO THIS TOGETHER,
WITH MY BACKGROUND IN MUSIC
AND YOUR BACKGROUND
IN PUBLISHING,
WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
PULL THIS THING OFF."
SO, YOU GUYS HAVE GOT
AN EXCLUSIVE RELATIONSHIP
WITH WALMART, RIGHT?
WE HAVE AN EXCLUSIVE
WITH WALMART
ON THE ZinePak
CONFIGURATION,
SO THE BRAD PAISLEY PACKAGE
THAT YOU'RE HOLDING,
THAT'S A WALMART PRODUCT.
OKAY.
NONE OF THE OTHER PRODUCT
ON THE TABLE IS WALMART PRODUCT.
SO, WE'VE GROWN
OUTSIDE OF RETAIL,
AND WE'VE GROWN
INTO TICKETING.
THE LITTLE, SMALL TICKET THAT
YOU GUYS HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU...
Herjavec: THIS ONE?
YES.
...THAT WAS THE TICKET
TO MUMFORD & SONS'
TOUR LAST SUMMER.
SO, WE CUSTOMIZED
ALL 140,000 TICKETS.
IT'S THE FIRST TIME
IT'S EVER BEEN DONE
ON SUCH
A LARGE SCALE BEFORE.
I JUST WANT TO
POINT SOMETHING OUT
ABOUT TRYING TO VALUE
WHAT YOU'RE WORTH TODAY.
YOU HAVE A MASSIVE RISK,
'CAUSE YOU HAVE ONE CUSTOMER.
LIKE, WHY AREN'T YOU TALKING
ABOUT BEST BUY AND TARGET
AND OTHER CUSTOMERS
TO DIVERSIFY YOUR REVENUE?
BECAUSE BEST BUY
AND TARGET SALES TOGETHER
IN MUSIC DON'T EQUAL
WHAT WALMART SELLS.
[ ALL TALKING ]
BAM! [ CHUCKLES ]
AND ONE OF THE THINGS
ABOUT OUR GROWTH --
WE TURN DOWN
ABOUT 50% OF THE PEOPLE
WHO COME TO US
ASKING FOR BUSINESS,
BECAUSE WE WANT TO
KEEP IT EXCLUSIVE.
WE WANT TO BE A PRODUCT
THAT'S JUST FOR SUPER FANS.
ALL RIGHT, I MEAN,
I'LL MAKE YOU AN OFFER
IN TERMS OF WHAT
I THINK IT'S WORTH, OKAY?
[ CHUCKLING ]
WHAT DO YOU THINK
IT'S WORTH, KEVIN?
UM, I WOULD DO
THE $725,000 FOR 35%.
THANK YOU FOR THE OFFER.
AND THAT'S BASICALLY
WHAT A VENTURE FIRM
WOULD GIVE YOU TODAY.
OTHERWISE, IT'S NOT COMMENSURATE
WITH THE RISK I'M TAKING.
WELL, WE DON'T SEE IT
AS A RISK,
BECAUSE, AS WE SAID,
WE'RE WORKING TO DO
MORE AND MORE OF OUR BUSINESS
OUTSIDE OF WALMART.
THE WALMART RELATIONSHIP
HAS BEEN AMAZING,
BECAUSE OUR HISTORY
IN 3 1/2 YEARS WITH WALMART
HAS ALLOWED US TO WORK WITH
75 DIFFERENT AMAZING ARTISTS.
THAT'S PHENOMENAL, BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
YOU'VE GOT TO DIVERSIFY.
WHAT DO YOU PROJECT YOUR SALES
TO BE NEXT YEAR?
$8 MILLION.
SO, WHY DO YOU NEED US?
SO, WE FEEL
VERY CONFIDENT
ABOUT OUR ABILITY
IN THE MUSIC SPACE.
WE'VE BEEN LIVING IT AND
BREATHING IT EVERY SINGLE DAY.
WHERE WE ARE
GOING TO NEED HELP
IS AS WE GROW
INTO OTHER VERTICALS.
SO, WE KNOW THAT THIS IS AN
AMAZING OPPORTUNITY FOR SPORTS.
AND, LOOK, I SEE WHAT
YOU GUYS ARE DOING. IT'S GREAT.
BUT I ALSO SEE
THE DESPERATION SIDE, TOO.
THE CHALLENGE IS
IT'S A DECLINING INDUSTRY,
AS YOU KNOW -- PHYSICAL CDs --
AND YOU'RE AWARE OF THAT,
AND YOU'RE LOOKING TO COMPLEMENT
ALL YOUR OTHER AREAS.
YOU HAVEN'T REALLY GIVEN US A
STRATEGY TO GET BEYOND WALMART.
I JUST --
I DON'T SEE THE FUTURE YET.
AND FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, MARK.
Kaupe: FOR US, IT'S NOT
GONNA BE A DYING THING,
BECAUSE THERE ARE SUPER FANS
OUT THERE FOR EVERYTHING.
THAT'S WHY WHOLE COMPANIES
LIKE COMIC-CON EXIST,
BECAUSE PEOPLE LOVE --
NASCAR, FORMULA 1.
YEAH, BUT YOU'RE STILL BUILT
AROUND PHYSICAL, RIGHT?
AND YOU'RE SAYING THEY WANT
TO HAVE SOMETHING PHYSICAL?
WE'RE GIVING PEOPLE SOMETHING
TO HOLD AND SOMETHING TO LOVE.
THAT'S BECAUSE SUPER FANS
LIKE TO HOLD IT.
John: OKAY, GUYS. LET ME --
LET ME -- LET ME HELP.
SO...
LISTEN, HERE, I'M GONNA TAKE
A FLIER WITH YOU.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $725,000
FOR 30%.
THANK YOU
FOR THE OFFER.
LADIES, YOU DID
AN AMAZING JOB TODAY.
I GET IT RIGHT AWAY, AND I GET
THE EXTENSION TO THE SUPER FAN.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT SOME
OF THE OTHER SHARKS ARE MISSING.
I GET IT, TOO.
I ALMOST THINK THAT, YOU KNOW,
SOMETIMES WHEN SOMETHING,
LIKE, JUST SEEMS TO GO AWAY,
SOME PEOPLE START
TO REALLY MISS IT MORE
AND WANT SOMETHING TANGIBLE --
AND EXCLUSIVE.
A KEEPSAKE.
EXACTLY.
YEAH.
I LOVE SUPPORTING GREAT,
SMART WOMEN.
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
AN OFFER.
I WOULD LIKE, THOUGH,
TO HAVE ROBERT COME IN WITH ME.
WE WOULD GIVE YOU $725,000
FOR 20%.
I'M HAPPY TO GO ALONG
WITH LORI.
I THINK
SHE'S THE RIGHT PARTNER.
I THINK WE BRING
DIFFERENT THINGS TO IT.
I'LL GO DOWN TO 25%.
SO, 25% FROM DAYMOND, WITH 20%
BETWEEN ROBERT AND LORI.
I'M $725,000 FOR 35%.
THAT'S ALL YOU'RE WORTH.
I'M SORRY.
AND I JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY --
OUR SALES WILL BE CLOSE
TO $4 MILLION THIS YEAR.
THAT $3 MILLION IS
OUR YEAR-TO-DATE.
I WILL ADJUST DOWN TO 30%,
THEN, IF THAT'S TRUE.
OH, YOU'RE SO GENEROUS.
THOSE ARE SERIOUS OFFERS.
THAT'S A LOT OF CASH
IN THE SHARK TANK.
WHAT ARE
YOU GUYS GONNA DO?
Narrator:
ONE SHARK IS OUT.
KIM AND BRITTANY
HAVE THREE OFFERS
FROM THE OTHER FOUR SHARKS
FOR THEIR CREATIVE-PACKAGING
COMPANY, ZinePak.
THOSE ARE SERIOUS OFFERS.
THAT'S A LOT OF CASH
IN THE SHARK TANK.
WHAT ARE YOU GUYS
GONNA DO?
UH, WE HAVE A TEAM OF SUCH
HARDWORKING WOMEN IN NEW YORK.
BEFORE WE LEFT, THEY SAID, "WE'D
LOVE FOR YOU TO NOT DO A DEAL
THAT VALUES YOU
AT LESS THAN $5 MILLION,
BECAUSE WE'VE WORKED SO HARD
AND DONE SO MUCH
TO HELP BUILD
THIS COMPANY UP."
SO, I'M WONDERING
IF YOU ALL WOULD BE INTERESTED
IN DOING THE DEAL AT 14%.
WOW.
NO. I'LL PASS ON THAT.
I'M OUT.
I'VE WORKED -- I'VE WORKED
SO HARD FOR THE LAST 45 YEARS
TO GET TO THIS SEAT.
I CAN ONLY
GO AS LOW AS 20%.
THANK YOU.
BRITTANY, YOU'RE AT 14%.
WE'RE AT 20%.
JUST OFFER THEM MORE MONEY.
WE WILL MEET YOU
IN THE MIDDLE
AT 17.5%.
DON'T DO IT.
LET US CONFER, PLEASE.
YES.
[ Laughing ] ALL RIGHT!
ALL RIGHT!
WE'RE WITH YOU GUYS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
WE'RE EXCITED.
WOW. YOU GUYS DID
AN AMAZING JOB.
Greiner:
YOUR WORK IS BEAUTIFUL.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, GUYS.
THANKS, GUYS.
NOW, SHE IS SOLID.
Greiner: I THINK THEY WERE --
I THINK YOU MADE A MISTAKE.
I THINK YOU DID A GOOD DEAL,
EXCEPT YOU OVERPAID
TWO YEARS AHEAD.
KEVIN.
ADMIT IT -- YOU CAN'T
GET IT RIGHT EVERY TIME.
John: I DON'T
THINK YOU OVERPAID.
LORI, IT DOESN'T MATTER
WHAT THEY SAY.
[ CHUCKLES ]
WE'RE REALLY EXCITED
ABOUT THE DEAL WE MADE.
IT WAS A LITTLE MORE EQUITY
THAN WE WANTED TO GIVE UP.
BUT FOR TWO SHARKS,
IT WAS A GAME WELL PLAYED.
Narrator: IN THE FIRST SEASON
OF "SHARK TANK,"
HEATH HALL
AND BRETT THOMPSON STRUCK A DEAL
WITH BARBARA CORCORAN
FOR THEIR BARBECUE SAUCE
AND SEASONING COMPANY,
PORK BARREL BBQ.
BARBARA,
ARE YOU MAKING AN OFFER?
I AM.
$50,000
FOR 50% OF THE BUSINESS.
WE'D LOVE
TO ACCEPT YOUR OFFER.
Narrator: LET'S SEE
HOW THEY'RE DOING NOW.
Thompson:
WHEN WE FIRST PITCHED,
WE WERE A SMALL COMPANY
WITH BARELY ANY SALES.
Hall: NOW, FIVE YEARS LATER, WE
HAVE OVER $10 MILLION IN SALES
AND A PORK BARREL BBQ
RESTAURANT.
THANK YOU. ENJOY.
OUR DISTRIBUTION
HAS EXPLODED.
WE'RE IN 5,000 STORES
WITH ANOTHER 3,000
ON THE WAY BY 2015.
THAT'S A LOT
OF BARBECUE SAUCE.
THERE IT IS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
LOOK AT THAT.
WITH BARBARA'S HELP,
OUR DREAM HAS COME TRUE.
OUR PRODUCTS HAVE MADE IT
ONTO THE SHELVES OF SAM'S CLUB.
$2 MILLION. CONGRATULATIONS.
THANKS, BARBARA.
Thompson: SAM'S CLUB PICKING UP
OUR PRODUCT IN ALL THEIR STORES
IS THE SINGLE BIGGEST ORDER
WE'VE EVER HAD --
OVER $2 MILLION.
HERE WE ARE.
WE FINALLY GOT A SPOT INDOORS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Corcoran:
HEATH AND BRETT HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO GET INTO SAM'S CLUB
FOR OVER THREE YEARS.
THEY CAMPED OUT
IN THE PARKING LOT
TRYING TO MEET
THE UPPER MANAGEMENT.
I INTRODUCED THEM TO
THE UPPER MANAGEMENT, AND BAM!
THE ORDER
FINALLY WENT THROUGH.
A TOAST?! HEY, HEY, HEY!
CHEERS!
WE'RE FORTUNATE TO BE
ABLE TO LIVE THE AMERICAN DREAM,
COOKING
THE AMERICAN CUISINE.
THERE'S NOTHING MORE AMERICAN
THAN TWO GUYS WITH A GOOD IDEA
AND REALLY BEING ABLE TO CREATE
SOMETHING FROM NOTHING.
Narrator: NEXT UP IS A BUSINESS
TO ENSURE YOU ALWAYS HAVE
THE BEST SEAT IN THE HOUSE.
HELLO.
MY NAME IS JAMIE MANNING.
AND I'M DEAN WHITNEY.
WE'RE HERE TODAY
FROM BOSTON, MASSACHUSETTS.
OUR COMPANY IS
SnagaStool.
WE ARE SEEKING
$120,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR AN 18% STAKE
IN OUR COMPANY.
SnagaStool IS
THE FIRST AND ONLY MOBILE APP
THAT ENSURES YOU'LL GET THE
BEST SEAT AT YOUR FAVORITE BAR.
AT THE BAR,
YOU GET THE BEST SERVICE,
THE BEST VIEW
OF THE TV,
AND YOU GET TO TALK
TO THE BARTENDER.
BUT AS WE ALL KNOW,
SOMETIMES IT'S IMPOSSIBLE
TO GET A SEAT
AT THE BAR.
NATURALLY, WE THOUGHT, "THERE'S
GOT TO BE AN APP FOR THAT."
BUT THERE WASN'T,
SO WE CREATED ONE.
NOW, WITH SnagaStool, YOU SIMPLY
PICK YOUR FAVORITE BAR --
LIKE THE SHARK TANK
BAR AND GRILL.
THEY MAKE A-A MEAN
"MARK CUBAN" LIBRE.
[ CHUCKLES ]
YOU COULD SELECT
THE DATE AND THE TIME
AND THE NUMBER
OF BAR STOOLS,
AND YOU GET TO SNAG
THE BEST SEAT IN THE HOUSE.
BARS LOVE SnagaStool.
IT CREATES NEW OPPORTUNITIES
TO FILL OFF-PEAK TIMES,
TO ATTRACT NEW CUSTOMERS,
AND TO CREATE LIFELONG FANS.
WE'VE CREATED AN INCREDIBLE
CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE,
AND WE'VE PROVEN THAT
WITH SOME AMAZING BARS.
SO, THE ONLY QUESTION
WE HAVE LEFT, SHARKS --
WHO WANTS
TO SNAG A STOOL?!
WHY DO I NEED YOU?
YOU SAID "OFF-PEAK TIMES."
IF I OWN THE BAR
AND IT'S OFF-PEAK,
THE BAR STOOL IS EMPTY
ANYWAY.
YOU DON'T
NEED TO RESERVE IT.
IF THE BAR IS
SUPER-BUSY,
WHAT'S THE BENEFIT TO ME
TO LEAVE THE BAR STOOL EMPTY
WAITING FOR YOU?
SOMEONE'S ALWAYS GONNA
SIT IN IT.
THAT'S RIGHT.
SO, THERE ARE TWO TIME PERIODS
ON SnagaStool,
AND WE'VE --
WE'VE IDENTIFIED THOSE
AS "PEAK TIMES"
AND "OFF-PEAK TIMES."
OKAY.
AND DURING
THE OFF-PEAK TIMES,
THAT'S WHEN BARS
WILL OFFER INCENTIVES,
LIKE A FREE BEER
OR A FREE APPETIZER,
TO ATTRACT PEOPLE TO THEIR BAR
TO FILL THOSE STOOLS.
OKAY, SO, I GO ON YOUR APP,
I GET A FREE BEER?
THAT'S RIGHT.
AND THE ADVANTAGE TO THE BAR
IS THEY GET CUSTOMERS IN
WHEN IT'S NOT BUSY.
ABSOLUTELY.
I COULD SEE, LIKE, PEOPLE JUST
REALLY BEING PISSED OFF...
IF THEY GO
INTO THEIR FAVORITE BAR...
YEAH.
...IT'S JAM-PACKED...
MM-HMM.
...AND THERE'S TWO SIGNS
LIKE THAT ON THE STOOLS.
Cuban: I COULD SEE
HAVING THOSE THERE
COULD BE LIKE --
MAKE IT INTERESTING, RIGHT?
"WHO'S COMING? WHO'S COMING?
IT'S RESERVED."
JUST LIKE WHEN YOU SEE
RESERVED TABLES.
I'M FROM BOSTON, OKAY? I'VE
NEVER HEARD OF THIS, ALL RIGHT?
LET'S TALK ABOUT
THE EL SUPREMO BAR STOOL --
UPSTAIRS BAR, GRILL 23,
PATS GAME ON A SUNDAY.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO
FOR ME THERE?
I'M NOT HAVING ANY TROUBLE
FILLING THAT BAR.
IN FACT, PEOPLE ARE SCREAMING
TO SIT IN ONE OF THOSE SEATS.
SO, HOW DOES IT WORK?
LET'S SAY I WANT TO GO
TO A PATS GAME
AND I DON'T WANT TO SIT THERE
FOR TWO HOURS TO KEEP MY SEAT.
IS THERE ANY WAY
I CAN USE YOUR APP
TO RESERVE MY SEAT
15 MINUTES BEFORE GAME TIME?
IT DEPENDS ON IF THE BAR HAS
ENOUGH INVENTORY OF STOOLS
AND IF THEY HAVEN'T
BEEN SNAGGED UP TO THAT POINT.
'CAUSE THEY ALLOCATE
A CERTAIN AMOUNT FOR YOU?
THAT'S RIGHT.
NOT ALL BAR STOOLS ARE --
ARE OPEN FOR THE SERVICE.
PEOPLE ARE WILLING TO PAY
FOR THIS EXPERIENCE.
SO, FOR PEOPLE
WHO AREN'T ABLE TO
GET TO THE BAR
TWO OR THREE HOURS EARLY --
PEOPLE
WHO ARE WORKING LATE,
PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE
THE ABILITY TO SIT
AND NURSE A BEER
FOR HOURS --
THESE BARS NOW HAVE
THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE --
SO, HOW DO YOU CHARGE?
HOW DO YOU CHARGE?
SO, WE CHARGE BY THE HOUR
OR BY THE GAME,
DEPENDING ON WHAT THE BAR
WOULD LIKE TO CHARGE.
OKAY, SO, GIVE ME AN EXAMPLE.
YEAH, SO -- SO, RIGHT NOW,
WE'VE PARTNERED
WITH SOME AMAZING BARS
IN THE BOSTON AREA.
HOW MANY?
SO, RIGHT NOW,
WE'RE WITH THREE BARS.
AND THAT'S WHAT --
THREE?
THREE BARS.
YEP. YEP.
GUYS, I GET YOU GOT TO CRAWL
BEFORE YOU BALL.
YEAH.
BUT WHY
JUST THREE BARS?
SO, WE JUST WANTED TO START OFF
WITH A PILOT,
AND WE REALLY WANTED TO
PARTNER WITH PEOPLE
WHO REALLY BELIEVED
IN THE CONCEPT.
WE'RE NOT GONNA TAKE REVENUE
FROM THESE BECAUSE --
ALL RIGHT.
YOU HAVE NO SALES.
LITTLE LESS.
IT'S -- IT'S OUR
PROOF OF CONCEPT.
THERE ARE SO MANY APPS
RIGHT NOW DESIGNED FOR BARS.
WHY ARE THEY EVEN
GOING TO DEAL WITH YOU
WHEN YOU'RE JUST
ONE OF 50 APPS
THAT ARE --
THAT ARE APPROACHING THEM?
SO, MARK,
IN -- IN OUR OPINION,
THE -- THE ART OF BARTENDING
HAS DIED SLOWLY.
WE'RE TRYING TO
GET BACK TO THE DAYS
WHEN A BARTENDER
REACHED ACROSS THE BAR
AND KNEW YOUR NAME,
KNEW WHO YOU WERE.
DON'T DISM--
YOU BETTER ROLL UP YOUR
PANT LEGS WHEN YOU SAY THAT,
RIGHT, BECAUSE --
DON'T DISMISS THIS,
BECAUSE IT MEANS A LOT.
BECAUSE THAT'S
HOW YOU BUILD LOYALTY
IS BY PROVIDING
AN ENHANCED CUSTOMER SERVICE.
YEAH, BUT THAT'S NOT
WHAT YOU'RE SELLING, THOUGH.
IT'S NOT --
O'Leary: EXCEPT, YOU KNOW,
THERE'S SOMETHING INTRIGUING
ABOUT YOUR CONCEPT
BECAUSE THERE'S
PROBABLY 25 STOOLS
UPSTAIRS AT GRILL 23,
ANOTHER 40 DOWNSTAIRS
AT THE DOWNSTAIRS BAR.
THEY ARE THE MOST COVETED SEATS
FOR ANY GAME IN BOSTON.
SO, WHY DO THEY NEED THEM?
BUT WAIT. HERE ME OUT ON THIS.
IF I COULD GO TO THEM SAY,
"LOOK, GIVE ME
20% OF YOUR INVENTORY,
AND I'LL GUARANTEE YOU
$200 FOR THAT SEAT."
BUT KEVIN'S ALMOST RIGHT, RIGHT?
AND HE'S --
HE'S ALWAYS RIGHT.
[ CHUCKLES ]
LOOK, THE ONLY WAY THAT I THINK
THIS IS GOING TO WORK
IS IF YOU WENT TO THIS 23,
AND YOU SAID "YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M GONNA GUARANTEE YOU
$10,000 UP FRONT."
THEN YOU HAVE INVENTORY.
WELL, IT'S NOT EVEN
FOR INVENTORY.
IT SHOWS THEM
THE VALUE THAT YOU BRING.
WELL, YOU HAVE A GUARANTEED
REVENUE STREAM, THEN.
RIGHT, IT'S NEWFOUND REVENUE.
THAT'S THE ONLY REASON
THEY'D DO IT.
YEAH, AND YOU JUST SAY,
"YOU KNOW WHAT?
GIVE ME FIVE BAR STOOLS
EVERY FRIDAY AND SATURDAY NIGHT.
I'M GONNA WRITE YOU
THE CHECK IN ADVANCE,
AND WHAT THEY SPEND ON THE BAR
IS STILL YOURS."
YOU GUYS KEEP ON SAYING,
"THERE'S VALUE,
THERE'S VALUE, THERE'S VALUE,"
BUT YOU HAVEN'T SHOWN
A WAY TO SELL THAT VALUE.
AND BECAUSE YOU HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO FIGURE THAT OUT,
I'M OUT.
I'M NOT A BAR GUY,
AND I CAN'T HELP YOU IN THIS.
I'M OUT.
[ LAUGHS ]
THE ADVANTAGE TO THE BAR IS
YOU'RE GONNA GET MORE MONEY
THAN YOU WOULD NORMALLY.
SO, IF I KNOW ON A BUSY NIGHT
I'M MAKING $500 A SEAT,
AND, GOING BACK
TO MARK'S POINT,
YOU'RE GONNA GUARANTEE ME
$1,000 ON A CONSISTENT BASIS,
I'M IN.
OTHERWISE,
I DON'T NEED YOU.
WELL, BARS ALSO --
YOU'RE SELLING ACCESS
TO SOMETHING
THAT, IN PEAK TIMES,
GETS SOLD OUT ANYWAY.
THE -- THE FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEM
IS YOU'RE SELLING
THE REAL ESTATE NOBODY WANTS
THROUGH YOUR SERVICE
AND NOT THE STUFF
THAT'S REALLY HARD TO GET.
FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
THERE'S DEFINITELY
SOMETHING TO IT,
BECAUSE PEOPLE
LIKE TO FEEL SPECIAL.
SO, BY BEING ABLE TO
RESERVE A SEAT,
THEY GET THE CONVENIENCE,
THEY GET TO WATCH THE GAME,
AND THEY ALSO FEEL SPECIAL.
SO I GET THAT.
MY PROBLEM IS
IT'S JUST TOO EARLY.
YOU ONLY HAVE THREE BARS.
YOU'RE JUST STARTING.
THERE'S NO PROOF
OF THE CONCEPT YET, FOR ME.
AND FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
AND THEN THERE WAS ONE.
ALL ROADS LEAD
BACK TO MR. WONDERFUL,
AND HERE WE ARE AGAIN.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S A KERNEL OF
A REALLY INTERESTING IDEA HERE.
MM-HMM.
THE TEST SHOULD BE
WITH A BAR THAT ACTUALLY HAS
INCREDIBLY VALUABLE REAL ESTATE.
I'VE BEEN GOING TO GRILL 23
FOR 20 YEARS WITH MY BUDDIES
TO WATCH PAT GAMES.
THERE IS NO PRICE I WOULDN'T PAY
TO SIT THERE WITH THEM, OKAY?
BUT THE HASSLE IS
I GOT TO GO TWO HOURS EARLY
TO ESTABLISH MY REAL ESTATE.
IF YOU CAME IN HERE
AND SAID,
"WE'VE CUT A DEAL
WITH GRILL 23,"
YOU'D HAVE A HELL
OF AN AUCTION GOING ON.
THAT'S NOT
WHAT YOU BROUGHT ME.
YOU BROUGHT ME SORT OF
"LET'S BRING
SOME INCREMENTAL DOLLARS IN
AT A REALLY BAD TIME."
I WANT TO MAKE MONEY
GETTING ACCESS
TO REAL ESTATE
THAT I COVET.
THAT'S WHAT THE INTERNET
WOULD BE GREAT AT.
THAT'S WHERE
YOUR MODEL WOULD WORK.
AND YOU SHOW ME A BAR LIKE
GRILL 23 AGREEING TO DO THAT,
THEN I KNOW YOU'VE GOT SOMETHING
THAT GOES NATIONWIDE.
I INVITE YOU BACK
WHEN IT'S FIXED,
AND I'M NOT PAYING A DIME MORE
THAN YOUR VALUATION TODAY,
'CAUSE I GAVE YOU
ALL THE GOOD IDEAS.
I MEAN, I SHOULD OWN
YOUR BUSINESS BY NOW.
NO, YOU TOOK MY GOOD IDEA.
WE JUST GAVE YOU A LESSON
ON HOW TO FIX IT.
THERE'S NOTHING TO
INVEST IN HERE. I'M OUT.
YOU GUYS DID NOT GIVE US
THESE IDEAS.
THESE IDEAS CAME TO US
IN THE LAST FIVE MONTHS
OF TESTING
WITH THESE BARS.
GUYS, I THINK WE'RE DONE HERE.
WE'LL SEE YOU AT GRILL 23.
THEY CAN'T GET A SEAT.
YEAH, THAT'S A PROBLEM.
THANK YOU.
GOOD LUCK, GUYS.
John: GOOD LUCK, GUYS.
Greiner: THANK YOU. GOOD LUCK.
Manning:
SnagaStool IS A TINDERBOX
READY TO JUST TAKE OFF,
AND WE'RE REALLY GONNA TAKE THIS
TO THE NEXT LEVEL
IN THE NEXT YEAR.
I'M ERIK.
AND I'M SASHA.
AND OUR COMPANY
IS BUCK MASON.
AND WE'RE BASED
IN LOS ANGELES, CALIFORNIA.
AMERICAN MEN ARE READY
FOR A DIFFERENT TYPE
OF FASHION BRAND --
ONE THAT'S ROOTED IN COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT SENSIBILITIES,
NOT CONNECTED
TO FASHION.
THIS IS A REAL
TROCHUS-SHELL BUTTON.
AND WE HAVE
A BUSINESS MODEL
THAT SIMPLIFIES
THE SHOPPING EXPERIENCE
AND MAKES IT IMPOSSIBLE
FOR GUYS TO MESS UP.
HOW'S THE NECKLINE
THIS TIME?
Erik: 20 3/8, BABY.
AMERICAN-MADE IS ABSOLUTELY
A PRIORITY FOR US.
MOST PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
THAT LESS THAN 2% OF CLOTHING
PURCHASED IN AMERICA IS
ACTUALLY MADE IN AMERICA.
WE REALLY NEED TO
PRESS THE COLLAR OUT
AND GET ALL THE WRINKLES OUT.
THE IDEA OF NOT HAVING
A PERSONAL RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE CRAFTSMEN MAKING
OUR JEANS, MAKING OUR SHIRTS
JUST DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE TO US.
YOUR TOTAL'S GONNA BE
88 BUCKS.
Sasha: SINCE WE'VE LAUNCHED
LESS THAN A YEAR AGO,
OUR BUSINESS HAS BEEN
GROWING RAPIDLY,
AND EVERY NEW PRODUCT
THAT WE CREATE
SELLS OUT IMMEDIATELY.
WE NEED THIS INVESTMENT
TO CREATE ENOUGH INVENTORY
TO KEEP UP WITH DEMAND.
THE SHARKS
SHOULDN'T INVEST IN US
JUST BECAUSE
WE'RE MADE IN AMERICA.
THEY SHOULD INVEST IN US
BECAUSE WE'RE PROVING
THAT AMERICAN-MADE CAN
ACTUALLY BE PROFITABLE,
AND WE'RE DOING THAT
DAY AFTER DAY.
HI, SHARKS.
I'M ERIK SCHNAKENBERG.
AND I'M SASHA KOEHN.
WE'RE FROM LOS ANGELES,
CALIFORNIA.
OUR COMPANY IS
BUCK MASON.
WE'RE SEEKING $200,000
IN EXCHANGE
FOR 8% OF OUR COMPANY.
GROWING UP, I ALWAYS THOUGHT
MY FATHER DRESSED COOL.
HE WORE THE EXACT SAME THING
EVERY DAY --
BEAT-UP BLUE JEANS,
A WHITE V-NECK "T,"
AND A FLANNEL
WORK SHIRT.
HE WAS A BRICK MASON,
SO I GUESS HE WASN'T
TRYING TO LOOK COOL.
HE WAS SIMPLY DRESSING
OUT OF FUNCTION.
THESE DAYS, IT'S PRETTY EASY
FOR A GUY TO GET OVERWHELMED
WHEN IT COMES TO SHOPPING --
TOO MANY CHOICES,
TOO MANY TRENDS,
TOO MANY PRODUCTS
COMING FROM COUNTRIES
WE'VE NEVER EVEN HEARD OF.
WE'VE CREATED BUCK MASON
TO PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY,
AMERICAN-MADE CLOTHING
AT AN ACCESSIBLE PRICE POINT.
WE FOCUS ON THE BASICS,
LIKE THE PERFECT T-SHIRT,
THE QUINTESSENTIAL BLUE JEAN,
AND THE CLASSIC
OXFORD SHIRT.
ON OUR WEBSITE,
WE SHOW OUR CUSTOMERS
HOW OUR PRODUCTS
ARE BEING MADE
AND WHO'S ACTUALLY
MAKING THEM.
WE CALL THIS AMERICAN-MADE
PRICE TRANSPARENCY.
AT BUCK MASON,
WE'RE IGNORING FASHION TRENDS.
IT'S NOT ABOUT STANDING OUT
OR FITTING IN.
IT'S ABOUT TASTE.
AND, LISTEN, WE'RE NOT
YOUR ORDINARY FASHION DESIGNERS.
WE'RE TWO MIDWESTERN GUYS
OBSESSED
WITH RECLAIMING
AMERICAN QUALITY.
SHARKS,
WHO WANTS TO HELP US BUILD
THE NEXT GREAT
AMERICAN CLOTHING BRAND?
CAN WE SEE
SOME OF THE CLOTHES?
OF COURSE.
YEAH, SASHA'S GONNA
HAND YOU SOME.
THANK YOU.
Cuban: YEAH,
SAVE MY SIZE FOR ME.
DO YOU HAVE
MY 28-INCH WAIST?
[ CHUCKLES ]
OH, THIS FEELS NICE.
Sasha: THANK YOU.
SO, ERIK, WALK ME THROUGH
HOW I BUY IT.
WHERE DO I GET THEM?
SURE.
WE SELL OUR PRODUCTS
DIRECT TO CONSUMER ONLINE
THROUGH THE BUCK MASON WEBSITE.
THERE'S TWO WAYS
TO PURCHASE PRODUCTS.
ONE IS THE INDIVIDUAL
SINGLE ITEMS,
WHICH, AS YOU CAN SEE,
ARE REALLY WEARABLE.
THEY'RE COOL NOW. THEY'LL
BE COOL 50 YEARS FROM NOW.
THERE IS ANOTHER WAY THAT WE
SELL MERCHANDISE ON THE SITE,
AND THAT'S
THROUGH CURATED PACKAGES.
SO, WHAT WE DO IS
WE PUT TOGETHER
THREE TO SIX PIECES
THAT YOU CANNOT MESS UP.
THE REASON
WHY IT WOULD WORK FOR YOU
IS BECAUSE IT'S FOR GUYS
THAT ARE JUST BUSY,
YOU KNOW, GUYS THAT DON'T
HAVE TIME TO SHOP.
OR GUYS THAT HAVE
NO FASHION SENSE.
[ CHUCKLES ]
AND WHAT DO YOU CHARGE
FOR A PAIR OF JEANS?
SO, THOSE JEANS
ARE $135.
$135 IS NOT CHEAP
FOR A PAIR OF JEANS.
THE $135
IS A GREAT VALUE
FOR THE PRODUCT
THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY MAKING.
FOR AMERICAN-MADE,
WE'RE ABOUT AS COMPETITIVE
AS YOU CAN GET FOR THE PRICE.
OKAY, AND WHAT ABOUT THE SHIRTS?
THE T-SHIRTS ARE $24.
BUTTON-DOWN SHIRTS
ARE $88.
SASHA, WHAT ARE
YOUR SALES SO FAR?
OUR SALES ARE $300,000.
IN WHAT TIME PERIOD?
EIGHT MONTHS.
WHAT DID YOU DO FOR A LIVING
BEFORE YOU DID THIS?
I'VE SPENT 15 YEARS
IN THE APPAREL BUSINESS.
AND I COME FROM THE TOTALLY
OPPOSITE END OF THE SPECTRUM.
I COME FROM
MORE TECH/MEDIA SIDE.
PRIOR TO STARTING
BUCK MASON WITH ERIK,
I CREATED AN
INTERACTIVE-CONTENT PLATFORM
CALLED
"THIS BUILT AMERICA"
PROFILING COMPANIES
THAT ARE REIMAGINING
AMERICAN MANUFACTURING.
OH, THAT'S COOL.
GOOD FOR YOU.
AND IT DID NOTHING BUT INSPIRE
ME TO BE COMPLETELY PASSIONATE
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING.
IF I BECOME A CUSTOMER,
AND I BUY, LET'S SAY,
A SHIRT AND JEANS,
I LIKE IT, HOW MANY
MORE TIMES IN A YEAR
DO I BUY?
WHAT'S THE LIFETIME VALUE
OF ONE OF THESE GUYS?
WELL, 38% OF OUR CUSTOMERS ARE
REPEAT IN THE LAST EIGHT MONTHS.
THAT'S GOOD.
AND OF THAT 38%,
10% HAVE PURCHASED
MORE THAN THREE TIMES.
THAT'S AMAZING.
THAT'S PRETTY GOOD.
SO, YOU GOT GUYS
BUYING A WHITE T-SHIRT,
TESTING US OUT,
REALIZING THEY LIKE IT,
COMING BACK AND BUYING
FIVE MORE AT A TIME.
AND THAT'S HOW GUYS SHOP.
WHAT MATTERS IS BRAND,
AND I UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO.
BUCK MASON IS AN AMERICAN,
HEARTFELT BRAND,
AND YOU'RE GONNA PICK
A PRICE POINT
WHERE YOU THINK YOUR
CUSTOMER-ACQUISITION COST ONLINE
IS GONNA BE LESS
THAN THEIR LIFETIME VALUE.
THAT'S WHAT
THIS BUSINESS MODEL IS.
'CAUSE I DON'T HEAR
A RETAIL ROLL-OUT STRATEGY.
I DON'T HEAR YOU PUTTING UP
RETAIL STORES IN SoHo.
IS HE RIGHT?
HE'S PARTIALLY RIGHT.
WE HAVE BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL
TO DATE WITH ACQUIRING CUSTOMERS
AT VERY LITTLE
TO ABSOLUTELY NO COST.
AND WE'VE BEEN DOING IT
THROUGH BOTH OUR SOCIAL
AND P.R. CHANNELS.
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF SUCCESS
THROUGH SOCIAL.
IT'S BEEN A VALUABLE TOOL
FOR US.
SO, GIVE US
YOUR METRICS ON SOCIAL.
INSTAGRAM'S BEEN
VERY HELPFUL.
WE HAVE
AN INFLUENCER PROGRAM, OKAY?
WE IDENTIFY PEOPLE
THAT WE RELATE TO
VERY WELL ON INSTAGRAM.
THEY HAVE VERY HIGH AMOUNTS
OF FOLLOWERS.
MOST OF THEM
ARE PHOTOGRAPHERS,
AND THE REASON WHY
WE FOCUS ON THEM
AND NOT SPECIFICALLY PUTTING
A LOT OF EFFORT
INTO FASHION BLOGGERS
IS 'CAUSE, MORE OR LESS,
WE'RE
AN ANTI-FASHION BRAND.
LIKE, WE'RE FOCUSING
ON THE BASICS AND THE CLASSICS.
WE'RE NOT FOLLOWING TRENDS.
THAT MAKES SENSE.
AND OUR CUSTOMER IS
FOLLOWING THESE PHOTOGRAPHERS,
NOT THE FASHION BLOGS.
THEY'RE NOT GQ GUYS.
AND WHAT ARE YOU DOING
FOR THESE PHOTOGRAPHERS?
ARE YOU GIVING THEM
AFFILIATE MONEY?
YEAH. IT'S A -- IT'S A --
YEAH, IT'S A LOT OF GIFTING.
IS YOUR VISION
TO TAKE THE $200,000
AND ACCELERATE
THE EXISTING BUSINESS MODEL,
OR ARE YOU GONNA EXPAND INTO
RETAIL OR GO INTO WHOLESALE?
PRIMARILY ONLINE.
DIRECT-TO-CONSUMER ONLINE, YEP.
SO, YOU'RE GONNA STAY
WITH THIS BUSINESS MODEL?
HOW MUCH
HAVE YOU GUYS INVESTED?
SASHA AND I
ARE THE ONLY INVESTORS.
WE'VE INVESTED $10,000.
CAN YOU DO $500,000 THIS YEAR?
IS THAT WHAT YOU FIGURE?
SURE. YEAH.
YES.
AND WHAT ARE
YOU GONNA MAKE ON THAT
AFTER YOU PAY YOURSELVES
SOMETHING?
WE JUST STARTED PAYING
OURSELVES.
WE THINK THAT
WE'LL MAKE ABOUT --
PROBABLY ABOUT $35,000
ON THAT.
OHH.
Cuban: GUYS, I THINK
WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS GREAT,
BUT I JUST DON'T WANT TO BE
IN THE CLOTHING BUSINESS.
IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
I'LL BE A CUSTOMER.
IT'S JUST NOT A FIT FOR ME.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS, I'M OUT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANKS, MARK.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
I THINK IT LOOKS GREAT,
AND I LOVE
THE MADE-IN-AMERICA STORY.
BUT I THINK
IF YOU WERE FARTHER AHEAD,
FARTHER DOWN THE ROAD -- I'M
NOT SURE HOW MUCH I COULD ADD
TO THE MIX OF KNOWING
WHAT'S REALLY RIGHT
TO HIT GUYS IN THE HEART
OF WHAT THEY WANT TO WEAR.
SO, FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE IT, LORI. THANK YOU.
Herjavec:
WELL, LOOK, GUYS.
INCREDIBLE THAT YOU GOT
TO THIS POINT WITH $10,000.
THAT'S REMARKABLE.
THANK YOU.
BUT I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND
HOW CUSTOMERS ARE FINDING YOU.
YEAH.
AND, FOR ME,
AS AN ONLINE COMPANY,
THAT'S THE STRUGGLE.
I'M OUT.
OKAY. APPRECIATE IT, ROB.
THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW, GUYS, BASICALLY,
COMPANIES IN CLOTHING TRADE
AT AROUND FOUR TIMES
THEIR CASH FLOW.
AND THEY'RE MUCH LARGER
THAN YOU ARE.
SO, YOU NEED TO BE MAKING
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN $600,000
AND $750,000 AFTER TAX TO GET
A VALUATION OF $2.5 MILLION.
YOU'VE COME IN
AND BEEN VERY AGGRESSIVE
IN TERMS
OF YOUR VALUATION HERE.
AND IT'S NOT CLEAR
WHAT YOU'RE WORTH YET.
IT'S A CONCEPT THAT'S STARTING
TO SHOW SOME TRACTION.
I LOVE THE BRANDING.
I REALLY DO.
BUT TO GET $200,000
OUT OF SOMEBODY,
I THINK YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
TO PART WITH HALF THE COMPANY.
I THINK WHAT
YOU'RE INVESTING IN HERE
IS, YOU KNOW, THE VISION
AND THE TALENT ON BOARD.
John:
COME ON, GUYS.
IF YOU'VE BEEN
IN THE BUSINESS THIS LONG,
YOU KNOW THAT THIS VALUATION
IS SOMEWHAT CRAZY.
$2.5 MILLION --
YOU'RE PUTTING A VALUE
ON WHAT YOU THINK YOU'RE GONNA
DO IN THE FUTURE, I GUESS.
THAT'S THE VALUE OF IT.
BUT MY DADDY DIDN'T HAVE
TWO CRYSTAL BALLS,
SO I CAN'T SEE
IN THE FUTURE, RIGHT?
THIS IS WAY TOO COSTLY FOR ME,
'CAUSE THIS IS MY INDUSTRY.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, DAYMOND.
SO, THERE'S ONE SHARK LEFT.
Herjavec: WOW, THE
MOST FASHIONABLE SHARK'S LEFT.
[ CHUCKLES ]
KEVIN?
I DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO HERE.
I'M -- I'M NOT SURE
WHAT YOU'RE WORTH RIGHT NOW.
YOU'RE WORTH A PARTNERSHIP
AND THE BEGINNING OF A BRAND
THAT NO ONE'S HEARD OF
UNTIL TODAY.
SO THE ONLY WAY
I CAN DO THIS DEAL IS
I'LL GIVE YOU $200,000,
I WANT 50%.
AND EVEN THAT'S GENEROUS.
THERE'S NO OTHER WAY TO DO IT,
BECAUSE YOU'RE SO FAR FROM --
FROM MAKING MONEY.
I MEAN, HOW ARE YOU GUYS
EVEN EATING?
THAT'S WHY THEY MAKE
SKINNY JEANS.
ERIK AIRBNB's HIS PLACE AND
CRASHES ON MY COUCH SOMETIMES.
WELL, THAT'S WHAT I MEAN.
I MEAN, THAT -- THAT
IS A START-UP.
YOU ARE GOVERNED BY GRAVITY.
John: IS THAT YOUR OFFER?
IT'S MY ONLY OFFER.
Greiner: NO, YOU GUYS --
I'LL GIVE YOU $200,000
FOR 50%.
Herjavec: YEAH.
I'LL HELP
GET YOUR WORD OUT.
I'M PROBABLY, OBVIOUSLY,
GONNA BE ONE OF YOUR CUSTOMERS
BECAUSE I LIKE WHAT YOU DO.
I DON'T KNOW
IF THAT'S GONNA BE HELPFUL.
I THINK IT IS.
I'M VERY FASHION FORWARD.
[ LAUGHS ]
SO, YOU KNOW, AT THE END OF
THE DAY, THAT'S THE ONLY OFFER
YOU'RE GONNA GET,
'CAUSE EVERYBODY ELSE IS OUT.
UH...
YOU KNOW,
THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE HAVE SCRAPED
AND CLAWED TO DO.
AND WE'RE BUILDING IT
BRICK BY BRICK,
AND, YOU KNOW,
FOR US TO GIVE UP
MORE THAN 15% EQUITY
IN THE COMPANY
AT THIS STAGE IN THE GAME
IS NOT SOMETHING
WE'D BE INTERESTED IN,
SO...
DO YOU UNDERSTAND
WHAT GRAVITY'S DONE TO YOU
HERE TODAY
IN THE SHARK TANK?
LOOKING AT THE DOLLARS
YOU GENERATE FROM IT
IN A COMMODITY BUSINESS,
THERE'S NO WAY
TO GIVE YOU THAT VALUE.
BUT STICK
TO YOUR GUNS, GUYS.
I MEAN, THERE -- THERE SHOULD BE
NO DESPERATION IN WHAT YOU DO.
MARK, BUT DO YOU THINK
I'M BEING UNFAIR?
YOU'VE ACCOMPLISHED A LOT.
YES, YOU'RE BEING UNFAIR.
WHY DON'T YOU COUNTER HIM?
UM, WE WOULD LIKE TO
COUNTEROFFER YOU
WITH $200,000 FOR 15%
PLUS A $100,000 LINE OF CREDIT.
15%?
CREDIT WOULD ONLY GO -- YES.
WOW.
THEY CHANGED THE OFFER.
FOR -- FOR $200,000?
$200,000.
PLUS $100,000 LINE OF CREDIT
SPECIFICALLY FOR INVENTORY.
AND THEY'LL THROW IN A
LIFETIME SUPPLY OF FREE CLOTHES.
YOU GET A LIFETIME SUPPLY
OF FREE CLOTHING.
[ LAUGHS ]
I CAN BUY A LOT OF JEANS
FOR $200,000.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
YOU KNOW, GUYS, I PROVIDE
A FACTORY FOR ALL MY COMPANIES.
WHEN YOU HAVE REAL SALES
AND IT'S WORKING,
IT'S NOT HARD
TO FINANCE THAT.
I DON'T EVEN WORRY
ABOUT THAT.
I'M STILL STUCK WITH HOW
I EVER GET MY MONEY BACK.
UNDER THE MODEL
YOU JUST GAVE ME,
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO MAKE
$2 MILLION AFTER TAX.
KEVIN, ALL YOU GOT TO DO IS
GO DOOR-TO-DOOR,
SELL SOME JEANS.
YEAH.
IN A FAIR MARKET,
IT WON'T TAKE YOU LONG.
GUYS, LOOK, I-I-I'M --
I'M -- IT'S THE FIRST --
ERIK, I'LL GIVE YOU
THE $200,000
PLUS $100,000 ON A LINE
OF CREDIT FOR 25%.
HMM, NOW IT GETS INTERESTING.
AND NOW IT GETS INTERESTING.
O'Leary: YEAH, I'M NOT GONNA
COMPETE WITH THAT.
I WOULDN'T
EVEN DO THAT DEAL,
SO, GUYS, IF YOU DON'T WANT
MY ORIGINAL OFFER, I'M OUT.
AND SINCE CLEARLY YOU DON'T,
DEAL WITH THAT.
YEAH, I'LL GO -- I'LL GO
DOWN TO 25% FROM KEVIN'S.
I THINK
YOU'RE GONNA MAKE IT.
I DON'T KNOW IF I SEE
THE HUGE FUTURE VISION.
YOU GOT TO TAKE ME OUT
FOR A BEER
AND EXPLAIN
HOW WE'RE GETTING CUSTOMERS,
BUT I THINK
YOU'RE GONNA MAKE IT.
UM...
WOULD YOU CONSIDER --
I WOULDN'T.
I WOULDN'T CONSIDER
ANYTHING BELOW THAT.
O'Leary: GUYS,
YOU'RE SO FAR FROM --
YOU NEED -- YOU NEED
$800,000 OF FREE CASH
TO GET ANYWHERE NEAR
EVEN THAT VALUE.
YEAH, I'M NOT TRYING
TO PUT YOU OVER A BARREL.
Cuban:
LOOK AT THIS WAY, GUYS --
LET ME -- LET ME --
LOOK, ROBERT'S A GREAT PARTNER.
AND I'M GONNA
SELL YOU ON ROBERT
AND WHY
YOU SHOULD DO THIS DEAL.
YOU'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO TURN
YOUR INVENTORY FROM THAT CASH
SO MANY TIMES AND CREATE SO MUCH
MORE VALUE WITH THAT CASH,
YOU'LL SWAMP
THE 10% DELTA.
THAT IS A HELL OF A DEAL.
THAT IS A HELL OF A DEAL
WITH WHAT YOU'RE AT TODAY.
YOU MAKE NO MONEY.
YOU'RE AIRBNB'ing YOUR HOUSE.
LET HIM -- LET HIM ANSWER.
ROBERT, ROBERT,
WE'RE HUGE FANS,
AND WE --
WE APPRECIATE YOUR OFFER.
UM...AT THIS POINT --
IT'S THE RIGHT OFFER, ERIK.
A-AT THIS POINT --
IT'S THE RIGHT OFFER.
DON'T MAKE A MISTAKE.
BECAUSE -- BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE -- BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE -- AND BECAUSE WE --
GUYS, YOU'RE OVERVALUING
THE EQUITY.
SOMETIMES, CASH IS
MORE VALUABLE THAN EQUITY.
[ Sarcastically ] OH, REALLY?
LET THE MAN SPEAK.
LOOK, GUYS, I AM
ALL ABOUT OWNING THE EQUITY
AS LONG AS YOU CAN.
BUT SOME BUSINESSES
REQUIRE CASH UP FRONT.
$300,000 IS GONNA
GET YOU INVENTORY.
YOU'RE GONNA TURN IT OVER.
YOU'RE GONNA GET
TO THAT NEXT STEP.
STOP AND THINK FOR A MINUTE
IF YOU'RE GONNA WALK OUT OF HERE
AND YOU'RE GOING TO
SAY TO YOURSELVES,
"WISH I HAD SAID 'YES.'"
ROBERT, WE KNOW
THAT WE'RE GONNA GET THERE.
FOR US, IT'S --
IT'S A MATTER OF WHEN.
AND FOR US TO GIVE UP --
BUT HOW QUICKLY?
FOR US TO GIVE UP
THAT MUCH EQUITY...
YOU MEAN 25%? IS IT 25%?
YOU'RE OVERVALUING
THE EQUITY, GUYS.
...IS NOT -- IS NOT
IN OUR INTEREST.
WE COULD DO THE SAME DEAL
FOR 17%.
NO, GUYS, NOW WE'RE GETTING
INTO THE REALM OF SILLY.
AN 8% DELTA
ON SOMETHING THIS NEW?
IT JUST DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
THIS IS REALLY
AN INVESTMENT ABOUT YOU GUYS
AND WHAT YOU'VE BUILT
SO FAR.
$200,000, 25%,
$100,000 LINE OF CREDIT.
WE'LL GET THERE QUICKLY
TOGETHER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
OFFER -- FOR YOUR OFFER, ROBERT.
UM,
WE HAVE TO DECLINE.
[ Scoffing ] OHH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
CONGRATS, GUYS. GOOD LUCK.
THANK YOU.
Greiner: GOOD LUCK.
WE'RE TRYING
TO BUILD SOMETHING
THAT WE COULD GIVE
TO OUR CHILDREN.
GIVING UP 25% 10 MONTHS
INTO THE LIFE OF OUR COMPANY
IS NOT IN THE BEST INTEREST
OF THE LONG HAUL.
I REALLY THINK THAT WAS
THE RIGHT OFFER FOR THEM.
WELCOME TO MY WORLD --
THE WORLD OF DESIGNERS.
[ LAUGHS ]
OH, COME ON.
NO CLUE.
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A FORMER NFL PLAYER
WITH A PRODUCT DESIGNED
TO SUPPORT AND PROTECT.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS BRYAN SCOTT.
I LIVE IN ATLANTA, GEORGIA,
AND MY COMPANY IS NOENE USA.
I'M HERE TODAY SEEKING
$100,000
IN EXCHANGE
FOR 10% OF MY COMPANY.
NOENE --
THEY'RE HIGH-TECH INSOLES
THAT ABSORB AND DISPERSE BOTH
LOW- AND HIGH-FREQUENCY SHOCKS
THAT ENTERS OUR BODIES WHENEVER
WE JUMP, RUN, OR EVEN WALK.
CURRENTLY, TO TRY
TO ALLEVIATE THIS PROBLEM,
WE BUY SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
IT'S SOFT, IT'S CUSHY, AND SO
WE THINK IT'LL FIX OUR PROBLEM.
BUT IT DOESN'T.
TAKE A LOOK.
THE BOUNCE OF THE BALL
IS JUST GONNA SHOW
HOW ENERGY IS
ACTUALLY TRANSFERRED
BACK UP INTO OUR BODIES
WITH EACH AND EVERY STEP
THAT WE TAKE.
IT'S CALLED
THE REBOUND EFFECT,
AND THAT REBOUND EFFECT CAUSES
CHRONIC PAIN AND INJURY.
NOENE, ON THE OTHER HAND,
IT'S A VISCOELASTIC,
VULCANIZED RUBBER.
AND IT'S REMARKABLY ABLE
TO ABSORB AND INTERNALLY
DISPERSE THE SHOCK,
LEAVING VERY LITTLE
TO NO REBOUND EFFECT.
SO, WHAT I'M GOING TO DO IS
TAKE THIS PIECE OF GLASS.
I'M GONNA TAKE THE NOENE,
AND I'M GONNA LAY IT ON TOP,
AND THEN I'M GONNA TAKE
THIS WEIGHTED BOCCIE BALL
AND DROP IT ON THE NOENE.
LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
Greiner: OH, MY GOD.
NO WAY.
SO, NOTICE...
OOH.
WOW.
...IT'S NOT DAMAGED.
BUT WITHOUT THE PROTECTION
OF NOENE...
Herjavec:
EFFECTIVE PRESENTATION.
I HAVE ONE OTHER DEMONSTRATION
TO SHOW REALLY QUICK.
SO, HERE IS
A REGULAR PINK RUBBER BALL,
AND HERE IS A RUBBER BALL
THAT'S MADE OF NOENE.
LET'S COMPARE THE DIFFERENCE.
OH, THAT'S COOL.
I HAVE SOME INSOLES
HERE FOR YOU,
BECAUSE EVERY SHOE AND SNEAKER
NEEDS A PAIR OF NOENE.
SO, I GUARANTEE YOU OUR PRODUCT
IS THINNER THAN A DIME.
GOT IT.
I WOULD CHALLENGE YOU
TO FIND ANOTHER PRODUCT
THAT'S THINNER THAN A DIME
TO PROTECT THE GLASS
LIKE I JUST DID.
SO, THESE
THAT I JUST HANDED OUT,
THESE ARE CALLED
OUR "UNDER INSOLES."
AND WHAT YOU DO IS
YOU TAKE OUT THE ORIGINAL INSOLE
OF YOUR SNEAKER,
YOU PUT THIS IN IN YOUR SNEAKER,
AND THEN YOU PUT
YOUR ORIGINAL INSOLE BACK IN.
IT'S SO THIN AND LIGHT,
IT DOESN'T CHANGE
THE FIT OF YOUR SHOE.
IN ADDITION
TO THE SUPPORT INSOLE,
WHAT WE WERE ABLE TO DO IS
ACTUALLY COME UP
WITH OUR
WOMEN'S HEEL VERSION.
AND THAT'S THE --
THE PROTOTYPE
WE ARE ACTUALLY IN
THE FINAL STAGES OF FINISHING.
SO, BRYAN,
HOW DID YOU INVENT THIS?
ARE YOU A DOCTOR?
ARE YOU A --
NO.
I AM NOT A DOCTOR,
AND I AM NOT A SCIENTIST.
I PLAYED IN THE NFL
FOR 10 YEARS.
YOU PLAYED IN THE NFL?
WHAT TEAM?
I DID. YES, I DID.
I STARTED -- I WAS DRAFTED
TO ATLANTA IN THE SECOND ROUND.
THREE YEARS THERE,
ONE YEAR IN NEW ORLEANS,
AND THEN SIX IN BUFFALO.
WOW.
SO, OUR FIRST QUARTER IS
WE'RE FOCUSING ON INSOLES.
WHY? BECAUSE IT'S A PRODUCT
THAT SELLS OVER IN EUROPE.
THE SECOND PHASE IS ACTUALLY
THE DIFFERENT SPORT APPLICATIONS
SUCH AS BASEBALL-BAT GRIPS,
BOXING GLOVES...
OH.
...TENNIS RACKETS --
TENNIS ELBOW, GOLF ELBOW,
ALL OF THAT.
TAKE US BACK TO THE --
THE BACKGROUND YOU HAVE
ON WHY THIS WORKS.
OKAY, SO, FIRST, NOENE,
IT'S A COMPANY OVER IN EUROPE
THAT HAS BEEN SELLING
FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
THEY OWN THE PRODUCT?
THEY OWN THE PRODUCT.
AND DO YOU MIND SHARING
THEIR SALES?
THEY BRING IN, ON AVERAGE,
ABOUT $1.2 MILLION ANNUALLY
ON INSOLES.
YOU'RE NOT BRINGING US
THE EUROPEAN STUFF, OBVIOUSLY.
DID YOU GUYS SIGN
A LICENSE WITH THEM?
YES, SO, WE SIGNED AN EXCLUSIVE
DISTRIBUTION AGREEMENT
TO WHERE WE HAVE
ALL OF THE U.S. AND CANADA
FOR THE SPORT INSOLES.
HOW MUCH DO YOU BUY
A UNIT FOR?
$6.
$6?
OOH, THAT'S EXPENSIVE.
OHH.
$6 FOR A PAIR?
YES, $6 FOR A PAIR.
RIGHT.
AND HOW MUCH
DO YOU SELL THEM FOR?
$29.99 IS
WHAT THEY RETAIL FOR.
6 BUCKS IS EXPENSIVE.
LIKE, IN BETWEEN AN ORTHOTIC...
NO, IT'S EXPENSIVE TO MAKE.
BUT $29.99
FOR A RETAIL PRICE...
John: IT'S NOT EXPENSIVE.
...IS NOT EXPENSIVE.
THE NEXT QUESTION
WILL PROVE THAT.
HOW MUCH ARE YOUR SALES
THIS LAST YEAR?
SO, WE PRIDE OUR PRODUCT
ON BEING THINNER THAN A DIME.
AND TO THIS DAY, CURRENTLY
WE HAVE NOT SOLD A DIME.
[ LAUGHS ]
AND THE REASON --
AND THE REASON IS --
[ GROANS ]
THAT'S A GOOD WAY
TO THROUGH TO US, BRYAN.
ARE YOU KIDDING?
I SHOULD HAVE PUT
THESE THINGS IN MY EAR
TO AVOID THE SHOCK.
YOU KNOW, IN BASKETBALL --
YOU KNOW, THE GUY IN BASKETBALL
WHO'S ALWAYS SAYING,
"I'M OPEN, I'M OPEN, COACH,"
AND THE COACH SAID,
"THERE'S A REASON
WHY YOU'RE OPEN, RIGHT?"
WELL, WAIT A SECOND.
FIRST, LET ME TAKE A STEP BACK
AND FIRST EXPLAIN WHY
WE HAVE NOT SOLD ANYTHING YET.
WE HAVEN'T TAKEN IT
TO MARKET YET.
I WAS INTRODUCED
TO THE COMPANY IN JANUARY.
SO,
DO YOU OWN EQUITY?
YES, I DO OWN EQUITY.
THAT'S CORRECT.
HOW MUCH EQUITY DO YOU HAVE?
SO, THERE'S FOUR OF US,
SO 25%.
AND WE'VE COMMITTED
$1 MILLION TO THIS PROJECT,
TO THIS COMPANY.
YOU'RE NOT COMMITTING
$1 MILLION.
JUST -- THAT'S RIDICULOUS.
IT MAKES NO SENSE.
WHY, SIR?
WHY WOULD YOU SPEND
THAT MUCH MONEY?
WE EACH HAVE $250,000
TO PUT IN.
SO, YOU'RE SAYING THAT --
YOU'RE SAYING THAT RIGHT NOW...
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
...YOU'VE DEDICATED --
IN CASE THERE'S A CASH CALL,
YOU HAVE A CASH CALL
UP TO $1 MILLION?
IF YOU NEED IT.
YES.
AND THAT'S WHERE I CAME
WITH THE $1 MILLION VALUATION.
IT WASN'T OFF OF PROJECTED SALES
OR WHAT WE CAN OR CAN'T DO.
OKAY, NOW WE'VE HEARD
YOUR STORY,
I CAN TELL YOU
A CERTAINTY.
BECAUSE OF THE FACT
THAT YOU REALLY HAVE
NO SALES YET, AT ALL,
THAT YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GET...
MM-HMM.
...A $1 MILLION VALUATION
FOR THIS,
EVEN IF THE PRODUCT HAS
THE MERITS YOU SUGGEST IT HAS.
AND ALSO,
THE STRUCTURE OF THIS DEAL
DOESN'T MAKE
A LOT OF SENSE.
THE BETTER PLACE
FOR YOU, BRYAN,
IS TO ACTUALLY NEGOTIATE
THE LICENSE DEAL WITH THEM
AND GET
A SMALL PIECE OF IT.
NOBODY WANTS TO
START FROM SCRATCH
AND BUILD A DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM
FOR ONE INSOLE.
THAT MAKES NO SENSE
WHATSOEVER.
IT'S NOT JUST ONE INSOLE, KEVIN.
WHAT IS IT?
WE WOULD LOVE -- WE WOULD
TAKE A LICENSING DEAL.
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO JUST BE
A DISTRIBUTION COMPANY.
YEAH, YOU WANT TO TAKE
ANY REVENUE YOU CAN GET
AND GET THIS THING GOING,
RIGHT?
WE JUST WANT TO GET IT GOING,
AND, HONESTLY --
BUT IT'S MORE PERSONAL
THAN JUST MONEY TO ME.
WELL, BRYAN, THE STORY, FOR ME,
JUST DOESN'T ADD UP.
I -- I'M NOT TRYING TO SAY
THAT YOU DID,
NECESSARILY, A BAD JOB,
BUT I JUST --
I DON'T SEE
THE APPLICATIONS.
I'M OUT.
OOH. ROBERT,
I'M VERY SORRY TO HEAR THAT.
I'M VERY SORRY
TO HEAR THAT.
AND I CAN UNDERSTAND
THE SKEPTICISM.
I CAN'T GET AROUND THE FACT
THAT THE UNIT COST IS $6,
WHICH MEANS THERE'S
A WHOLE LOT OF WORK.
IT'S AN INCREDIBLE
AMOUNT OF WORK.
IT IS A LOT OF WORK, BUT, KEVIN,
CAN I JUST STAY THIS --
A WISE COACH ONCE TOLD ME,
"YOU CANNOT CLIMB
TO THE TOP OF A MOUNTAIN
IF THE SIDES ARE SMOOTH."
NO, I TOTALLY GET ALL THAT.
AND, YES, THERE IS WORK, BUT --
I WOULD WANT 50%.
I'D WANT HALF THE COMPANY
FOR THE AMOUNT OF WORK
AHEAD OF ME.
SO, I'M OUT.
OKAY. I'M SORRY
TO HEAR THAT, KEVIN.
Greiner: I THINK
IT'S INTERESTING.
MM-HMM. OKAY.
I WILL DEFINITELY
BE A TESTER.
BUT BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW
FOR SURE...
MM-HMM.
...FOR THAT REASON
I'M OUT.
MAN, I'M SORRY
TO HEAR THAT, LORI.
I WAS HOPING THE WOMEN'S HEELS
THROUGH QVC --
BRYAN, I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
AN OFFER.
BUT THERE'S
A LOT OF CONTINGENCIES.
Narrator:
THREE SHARKS ARE OUT,
BUT MARK WANTS TO MAKE AN OFFER
FOR BRYAN'S INSOLE COMPANY,
NOENE.
IF THE SCIENCE
BEHIND THIS IS LEGIT...
YES.
...THEN I'M INTERESTED.
OKAY.
RIGHT?
SO, WE'RE GONNA DO
OUR DUE DILIGENCE.
YES.
BUT I'M GONNA OFFER YOU...
MM-HMM.
...$100,000 FOR 20%.
OKAY.
ONE MORE CONTINGENCY IS YOU GOT
TO CONVINCE THIS GUY TO COME IN
AS MY PARTNER, BECAUSE
HE OWNS ETONIC BRAND, RIGHT?
OKAY. MM. OKAY.
AND I THINK THAT
IF THIS TRULY DOES WORK,
THEN MAKING IT
AS PART OF A SHOE
WOULD BE A UNIQUE VALUE ADD...
MM-HMM.
AND I WANT TO SEE
IF HE BELIEVES IN THAT.
AND CUBAN'S RIGHT. WE --
WE PURCHASED THE BRAND ETONIC.
MM-HMM.
AND IT'S BEEN THREE YEARS
WITH US WORKING
ON THE -- THE RUNNING SHOE
BECAUSE, GUYS LIKE ROBERT --
YOU GIVE THEM THE WRONG SHOE,
YOU'RE DEAD.
THAT'S IT.
I COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND.
SO, WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO,
DAYMOND?
I'M GONNA GO IN WITH CUBAN
AND GIVE YOU AN OFFER --
$100,000
FOR 20% ON MY SIDE,
AND IT SOUNDS LIKE $100,000
FOR 20% --
OH, SO YOU WANT 40%?
I THOUGHT WE'D JUST SPLIT IT.
OH, NO. OH, NO.
OKAY.
THAT'S YOUR CALL.
OOH.
[ CLEARS THROAT ]
GOT TO MAKE
A DECISION, THEN.
I KNOW I WOULD DEFINITELY
GET MY HEAD CUT OFF...
AND YOU'VE GOT NOTHING
RIGHT NOW. YOU'VE GOT NOTHING.
...IF I GAVE UP 40%.
WELL, BUT YOU THINK OF IT
LIKE THIS --
YOU'RE GETTING TWO SHARKS.
RIGHT.
ONE WITH AN IMMEDIATE USE
FOR IT.
MM-HMM.
RIGHT?
SO, NOW YOU HAVE ME
ON THIS SIDE.
I THINK YOU KNOW TONY
FROM ZAPPOS, RIGHT?
YEP. YEP.
SO, WE HAVE A GOOD AMOUNT
OF RESOURCES.
YEAH, LOOK, I DID WORK
WITH SKECHERS.
THEY'D BRING US IN
IN A HEARTBEAT.
OH, ROBERT GREENBERG
FROM SKECHERS, AS WELL.
YEAH, ROBERT, YEAH.
O'Leary: YOU'VE GOT AN OFFER.
RIGHT.
YOU'VE GOT $200,000
FOR 40%.
EACH SHARK THAT'S INTERESTED
WANTS 20%.
ON THE OTHER HAND, THESE TWO
ARE THE RIGHT PARTNERS.
MM-HMM.
WHAT ARE
YOU GOING TO DO?
YOU CAN COUNTER.
YES, I DEFINITELY
WOULD LOVE TO COUNTER.
SO, IF BOTH OF YOU WANTED
TO GIVE $100,000 FOR 25%.
I LIKED IT AT THE 30%.
30% SOUNDS REALLY NICE.
30%, WE GOT IT.
YOU HAVE A DEAL.
DONE.
ALL RIGHT.
[ LAUGHS ] THAT'S RIGHT.
NO, MAN. YOU GOOD. YOU GOOD.
APPRECIATE YOU, SIR.
APPRECIATE IT.
YOU BETTER BE TELLING ME THE
TRUTH, OR I'M COMING AFTER YOU.
MY MAN, YOU WILL NOT
BE DISAPPOINTED.
JUST WAIT
TILL YOU SEE IT.
AND IF YOU'RE LYING TO ME,
I'M JUST GONNA RUN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Greiner: GOOD LUCK.
Scott: THE THING THAT HAS
ALWAYS MOTIVATED ME IS
TO MAKE PEOPLE PROUD.
AND I WANT BOTH MARK AND DAYMOND
TO SEE, AT THE END OF ALL THIS,
THAT, "MAN, BRYAN CAME THROUGH.
HE REALLY MADE US PROUD."